the Joe Rogan experience I was a
graduate student studying bats in I was
in Michigan and I was interested in
evolutionary trade-offs that's my
signature thing and there was a very
good piece of work from a guy new George
Williams great evolutionary biologist
about the evolution of senescence that
is to say the process by which we grow
feeble and inefficient with age but most
people call aging and basically that's
classic paper explained why it is that
creatures like us get old and die and
the answer was basically this that you
have a genome that's complex
it's full of genes but there aren't
enough genes to have a gene for every
trait that you have in fact they're a
tiny fraction of the number of genes you
would need to cover all of the various
characteristics you have so genes always
do multiple things and in the case when
a gene does something that's very good
for you when you're young at some cost
when you're old selection tends to favor
it because you may not live long enough
to suffer the cost and so if you have
the trait that makes you powerful when
you're young and you've got some cost
that you're gonna pay when you're old
but you're not gonna live to get it it
may be a freebie right so selection sees
early life much more clearly than it
sees late life and it prefers things
that help you early even at a cost of
harming you late that's the basic answer
it's called the antagonistic pleiotropy
theory of senescence but at the point
that I started working we knew that this
was right
we could tell that the hypothesis was
true because it matched all sorts of
observations about wild creatures
certain creatures live longer than
others even when you correct for things
like body size so creatures that fly
live longer than creatures that are of
the same type and size that don't fly
why because they can fly away from
danger if you can fly away from danger
you're more likely to make it to an
older age the better selection can see
the harms that afflict you when you get
there so selection doesn't
for a bias in favor of youth if you can
fly away from danger same thing applies
if your poisonous if you have a shell if
you have a really good defense then
selection sees your late life better
okay so we knew that this hypothesis was
right but what we had never found at the
point that I was working in the very
late 90s on this was a gene that matched
the description
we knew that selection was finding these
genes and accumulating them but we had
never found one of the genes in question
and that was very conspicuous I called
that the missing pleiotropy
so anyway I was sort of on alert about
this it was a curious fact and I saw a
talk given by somebody who was talking
about telomeres and he was talking about
telomeres in their relationship to
cancer so telomeres are repetitive
sequences of DNA at the ends of our
chromosomes and they grow shorter every
time a cell divides right so it's like a
fuse or a counter that ticks down each
cell division and it drops to zero and
in or not to zero but it drops to a
number that the cell refuses to divide
after that and some people were working
in one set of labs on the possibility
that this was causing us to grow feeble
with age because if your cells can't
divide anymore then they won't replace
themselves and your tissues won't be
able to maintain right another group was
studying this question of telomeres with
relation to cancer and they were saying
Eureka every time we look in a cancer it
has this enzyme called telomerase turned
on which elongates telomeres and these
two groups were not talking to each
other they were each claiming that they
were about to cure their respective
disease one group was saying if we can
activate telomerase then we can lengthen
your life and the other group was saying
if we can turn off to long race we can
cure cancer all right and I put two and
two together and I said this is the
missing playa trophy here we have
something that is protecting us it's
helping us in youth we have a counter
that is limiting the number of times a
cell can divide and presumably
preventing cancer right and
cost is you can't maintain your tissues
forever so you grow feeble and
inefficient so that made a hell of a lot
of sense to me I couldn't convince
anybody else that this was sensible I
couldn't even get them to understand
what I was saying because in
evolutionary biology there has
traditionally been a bias not in against
mechanism the study of cellular biology
not because there's anything wrong with
studying cellular biology as an
evolutionary phenomenon but because
early in the study of evolution we just
didn't have the tools to look into the
cells so evolutionary biologists got
used to thinking about the form of
creatures and the behavior of creatures
but not thinking about the internal
mechanisms because it just wasn't a lot
that could be said anyway I retained an
interest in the cellular biology I saw
these two things that needed to be
connected and I started to work on the
puzzle it turned out that that
hypothesis would answer a great many
questions that were otherwise very
difficult to answer with respect to how
aging functions but there was one huge
obstacle the obstacle was that a fact
that was well known about mice did not
fit with the idea that telomeres were
fundamental to the aging process and the
fact that was known was that mice had
extremely long telomeres and yet they
lived short lives so if it were true
that the length of your telomeres
dictated how quickly you were going to
age then a tiny creature with very long
telomeres ought to be able to replace
his tissues really well and it should it
should it should age very very slowly so
I thought there's got to be something
wrong with this the hypothesis answers
to many questions for that obstacle to
be real and I thought maybe it's maybe
one person has run a test and everybody
else is just parroting it and I went and
I looked and that wasn't the case and I
finally realized that all of the mice
that we had been looked at were coming
from one source that there was a
laboratory in Bar Harbor Maine called
the Jax lab that was the source for all
of the mice being used in all of the
laboratory
in the country and I started to wonder
is there something going on at that
maybe mouse telomeres aren't long the
ultra long telomeres of mice aren't real
maybe that's a feature of laboratory
mice and wild mice would have short
telomeres in which case the hypothesis
would make sense and I called up one of
the leading people in the field woman
named Carol Greider who's now won a
Nobel Prize and I said Carol you don't
know me I'm an evolutionary biology
graduate student I have a question for
you is it possible that all mice don't
have long telomeres that that's really
just laboratory mice and she said well I
think mice have long telomeres but it's
interesting if you order must spread us
rather than mus musculus and you order
them from europe then how long their
telomeres are depends on what supplier
you get them from so this is interesting
so anyway we both agreed that it was
really interesting she decided she was
gonna test the hypothesis she put her
graduate student Mike Heymann on the
case we exchanged some emails and anyway
they tested it and they got some mice
that weren't really wild but they were
much more recently in captivity and lo
and behold they had short telomeres okay
so that was an amazing moment
my prediction had turned out to be true
which meant a that my hypothesis about
senescence and cancer and aging might
well be true that was important but it
also raised a bunch of really difficult
problems one was if it is true that all
the mice that are being used to study
physiology are broken in this way then
how are we blinding ourselves is it
possible that we are using all of these
mice that would be terrible models for
wound healing for senescence for cancer
for a whole number of things how is it
that we are allowing ourselves to take
these mice who have been altered and
using them as models for normal
physiology and the other problem maybe
even more serious was that we use these
animals in drug safety testing
and the way we use them is if you think
about if you'd come up with a drug that
you thought was useful and you wanted to
test whether it was safe to administer
it to people you can't really afford to
give people a drug and then wait 4050
years to figure out whether you've
shortened their lives right so at the
point that you start testing these
things on humans you're really in the
final stage the way we test whether a
drug is safe for long-term use or
whether it is safe for your long term
life based on short use is we give large
doses of it to small animals that live
short lives on the assumption that if
it's going to shorten your 80 or 90 year
life by 10 or 20 years that it will
shorten a mouse's life long enough to
see it but here's the problem if you've
altered a mouse in the laboratory
environment by favoring the radical
elongation of its telomeres then it has
the ability to replace its tissues in
definitely a toxin that will harm you by
killing tissue may not harm that Mouse
in fact it may actually help it because
these mice are very cancer prone so when
we give a toxin that will damage you to
a mouse that is highly resistant to
tissue damage you may slow down its
tumors and in fact we've seen this a
number of times where a drug is given to
mice and we get back to the paradoxical
result not only is it not toxic it
actually makes the mice live a little
longer all right so my contention is
that we had a problem where we were
testing drugs to see if they were safe
on animals that were predisposed to tell
us that they were and then when those
drugs were released into the human
population it turned out they were not
safe and people died now the problem is
I was absolutely unable to alert the
world to this problem for reasons that
still elude me I published my paper I
went through I don't think we need to
bore your audience especially if they've
been through Erik's description with the
details of what happened in the attempt
to bring this to public attention but
the world of scientists working on the
question was unwilling to respond to the
discovery that their model organism had
this fatal flaw that was going to
predispose us to see certain things and
not other things in the laboratory
environment the governmental commission
that was charged with studying the Vioxx
scandal which I believe was likely the
result of something like this in its
300-page report doesn't mention mice it
doesn't the Vioxx scandal which was it
was a drug for arthritis correct yeah
gay people strokes yeah it did heart
damage yeah and so anyway heart damage
is actually probably not heart damage
and by that what I mean is if you take a
drug a substance that damages tissues in
the human body it will show up as heart
damage because of the special nature of
the heart so let's say that you took
some drug that you know killed every
10,000 cell or every thousand cell that
would be destructive all over your body
the heart though is a special tissue the
heart has a very low capacity for self
repair at a cellular level very low for
reasons we could go into if you wanted
but because it has a low capacity for
self repair it is also very vulnerable
to something that does some kind of
general tissue damage and it's also an
organ that when it fails it's absolutely
conspicuous so you would expect that if
we had substances that were body wide
toxins and we released them into the
public having tested them on mice and
not discovering that they were dangerous
that you would see relatively young
people die from heart conditions which
is where we would detect that there's a
problem before we would detect it
anywhere else
hmm so anyway the the government studied
this problem after after Vioxx and it
put together a report and the reports
300 pages it doesn't mention mice it
doesn't mention the genus Massa do you
think they did that to protect
themselves well what I know is that I
attempted to call their attention after
the report came out I looked at it and
you
it had a physical form but it also had
it lives online you can search it and I
could see that telomeres weren't
mentioned mice weren't mentioned rodents
aren't mentioned and so I tried to alert
them to the fact that they had screwed
up and I they blew me off they wouldn't
talk to me so that is it raises a
question and I to this day cannot answer
the question I can't even say whether or
not so when I've tried to raise this
issue I have run into various kinds of
resistance if I raise it with
journalists what I get back is typically
I get interest back at first and they
say okay I'm very interested in the
story I'm gonna pursue it I'm gonna make
a few phone calls and then they come
back to me and they either they go
silent or they say well I talked to some
people and they said it's been taken
care of
right well I don't know what it's been
taken care of means I published a paper
that said here's a hypothesis about
what's going on here's my I proposed a
mechanism whereby telomere elongation
would have happened in the breeding
colonies in question and it's been taken
care of it's a very strange way to
describe something that could be an
enormous problem well not only let's say
that it was taken here right let's say
that they have altered the the breeding
protocol and they fixed the problem you
still have all those drug tests that
they've done for you got all those drug
tests you've got all of the papers
you've got my paper which proposes a
hypothesis and I have a right to say
actually it turns out to be correct or
it wasn't all right but so anyway we got
back all of these weird answers it's
been taken care of or even more curious
is the argument well everybody knows
that the mice are bad models which is
insane because this telomere actually
got that response yeah from several
people I went to several different
journalists and it wasn't that I was
told who they contacted what I was told
was that they contacted somebody and
this is what they heard and so they
their enthusiasm evaporated at the point
they make a phone call
so did were they not aware of the
consequences of this
problem with these mice so again this is
we have a serious problem
it's not about mice it's not about viral
adji right it's a general systemic
failure of a reason so what I
encountered as a young somewhat naive
graduate student was an instance which
frankly woke me up to the fact that my
colleagues even when human life was at
on the line we're going to pretend they
didn't know what was going on it's quite
possible they didn't know until I had
put out my hypothesis and Carol Greider
who later pretended she didn't know what
I was talking about published the
empirical work that revealed that indeed
labra lab mice are unusual in having
long telomeres after that work was out
there's no excuse for not investigating
what the consequences were I cannot
explain it except to say that the
culture of science has become so rotten
that this sort of thing is maybe
standard operating procedure just
protecting their ass and protecting the
ass of those who give them jobs and and
all the work that's been done that sort
of establishes that they should be doing
these tests in the first place
I'm sure they tell themselves some story
in which they're the heroes and they are
protecting us from something but I I
look at my own medicine cabinet and even
though I am aware of what likely
happened I am in no position to protect
myself on my family the only way to be
protected from the downstream
consequences of this error is to just
not take pharmaceuticals Jesus Christ
yeah it's a it's a it's a really huge
problem and the response of the system
generally to shut down the lone
individual trying to point out a serious
problem is it's just breathtaking and
when you've when you've seen it when
you've lived it you you never go back
you know you've looked into the
of something that is willing to ignore I
mean it's willing to ignore it not only
human life but it is willing to ignore
the requirements of good science
[Applause]